Abbi, I gotta ask you, you did a Lego short.
I did.
A short film, very popular.
(audience cheers)
And in it
My mom.
My mom's here, my mom's here.
You played a chicken.
Yes.
What was the idea behind that
and was it hard for you to do
the voice, vocally, of a chicken?
It was interesting.
I got in there and it was just me and Charlie, the director,
and I'm just conversing with Jackie Chan,
as this chicken, and it's been difficult,
I've been typecast as chickens since the film came out
but like, you know, actually, it's going pretty well.
It's going pretty well.
There's a lot of roles for really amazing chickens,
you'd be surprised (laughs)
So, look out for 'em!
But, yeah, I basically just balked.
I balked dialogue.
Balked?
Right, over and over again and did you have to do
nuances of balk?
For like four hours.
Yes, Charlie, it got very emotional.
(audience laughs)
It was a cat and mouse game, with me and Jackie Chan
and I had to, I balked like,
the direction we'd be like,
balk like you finally found your destiny.
(audience laughs)
(rapid noises) balk again!
Just give me a second!
It would be like,
(audience laughs)
Balk!
(laughs)
(applause)
Very good!
You get it, you see why.